Good evening.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, but I hope it has been happy.
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato sambha sambodasa.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Samba Sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-awakened one.
So yesterday we had the terrible revelation that the scriptures have fake news.
Or if you prefer, alternative facts.
So obviously, there are conversations where, who knows, there wouldn't have been any Buddhist monk or anybody there.
For instance, between Tapasi, the monk who belonged to the Jain order, and of course, the Jain leader.
And then the conversation between them and Upali.
So a lot of it is, shall we say,
made up or created, is created, very created.
So, of course, that does leave us with the question, well, you know, what are we to believe?
Well, we can relieve ourselves of that question because, of course, the Dharma isn't something we're supposed to believe.
It's something we're supposed to investigate.
And we have to separate out all the stories and the exaggerations and the hagiography
which is the description of the saints and how it's all built up over time.
And remember that these scriptures weren't written down for, what, 800 years, I think, something like that.
In Sri Lanka, they were written down in the 5th century Common Era.
And so there was eight centuries where stories were being told, handed about, etc.
And, of course, we have another set of scriptures
which is only in Chinese from another sect called the Savastavadin group.
And Bhikkhu Analyo has been studying those and he uses them a great deal in his books.
And we always get the same message, but of course there are variations.
So what is it that we know the Buddha taught, you see?
That's the question.
with the Bodhi Pakiya Dhamma, which translates as those factors that you need to become fully liberated.
And there's 37 of them and they're well attested to.
And what I'm looking at now is the sort of 77, which is the Maha Sakkuru Daya.
uh discourse so it's a discourse that's given to this uh wanderer called and um we'll we won't start at the beginning we'll start somewhere in the middle because right here in the middle of this are these bodhi bakia dhamma and uh you'll know most of them though one section may come as as a little surprise
So the first, so there's 37.
So the first four are, of course, the four foundations of mindfulness.
So again, I proclaim to my disciples the way to develop the four foundations of mindfulness.
Here, a meditator abides, contemplating the body as body, ardent, fully aware and mindful, having put away covetousness and grief for the world.
Any desire for worldly things
And of course, the sadness of any loss.
And so he abides contemplating feelings as feelings.
I prefer it to be translated feelings in feelings because it's a direction as to what we do when we're practicing vipassana.
We're trying to get into the feelings.
I always remember Sayuru Upandita always talked about plunging, plunging into the feelings.
And contemplating the mind, heart-mind, remember, it's not thinking, it's citta.
The word citta combines both our emotional and thought life.
So it's contemplating the heart-mind in the heart-mind and contemplating, now it's translated, Dikubori translated as mind-objects.
But if you remember, we did go through the discourse on how to establish mindfulness.
And they include such things as the hindrances, the seven factors of enlightenment and so on, and the Four Noble Truths.
So that's the first four of the 37 Bodhi Pakiya Dhamma, or the Dhamma that you need to become fully liberated.
Now, the next one is to do with striving, the four great strivings.
So it's put in a sort of slightly difficult way.
But again, we've done this.
Hirabiku awakens zeal, real ardent effort for the non-arising of unarisen, evil, unwholesome states.
So in other words, not to allow unwholesome states to take us, to take us, to control us.
And he makes effort, arouses energy and exerts his mind and strives.
So a real effort there to make sure that any time some unwholesomeness comes, we're very quick to not indulge in it.
And in the same way to abandon those arisen unwholesome states.
So when unwholesome states arise and we find ourselves drawn towards them, to abandon them.
So that's the striving when it comes to unwholesome states.
And when it comes to wholesome states, of course, he awakens the zeal for the arising of unarisen wholesome states.
So whenever there's an opportunity to develop a virtue, then that's what we do.
And he awakens the zeal for the continuance, non-disappearance,
strengthening increase and fulfillment by development of the arisen wholesome states so uh so to do that he must arouse effort energy exerts his mind and strives so there's your four great efforts and it's of course to do with our uh with our ethics with our internal morality um beautiful states of mind and getting rid of those that we see as
unwholesome and unskillful.
So that definitely the Buddha teaches.
Now the next one are the four bases of spiritual power.
That's how it's translated, but I think it's better to see it also translated as success.
Now it puts a spiritual success, which is true, of course, but it also, these qualities can also be used for success in ordinary daily activity, in ordinary daily life.
So I have proclaimed to my disciples the way to develop the four bases of spiritual power.
The basis here, here he develops or here they develop the basis for spiritual power consisting of concentration due to zeal and determined striving.
So now this is the, the word is chanda.
um and it's it gives the it gives that feel of really wanting something really wanting something uh it's uh remember the word tanha which comes up in the uh in the dependent origination has that specific meaning of wrong desire often translated as craving which is a bit strong
thirst and then you have this word chanda which means also desire but you can have wrong desire and right desire mitcha chanda and samatha chanda so here it's developing that real desire for spiritual progress or in ordinary daily life just you know for success in the work you're doing
And he develops the spiritual power consisting in concentration due to the energy and determined striving.
So again, the desire is not enough.
You've got to put your energy into it.
Okay.
And that brings about success.
And then he develops the spiritual power consisting in concentration due to the purity of the mind, here the heart mind, and determined striving.
So again, it's to do with purifying the mind, making sure that the wrong intentions aren't creeping in there.
So for instance, even in ordinary daily life,
When you're, say, at your work, the most wholesome purpose that you might put to your work, whatever you do, is one of service.
But if it's, of course, to impress somebody just to make money, then it becomes slightly corrupt.
So one has to have a purity of heart, and then it becomes a spiritual practice.
So you don't separate ordinary daily life from sitting meditation.
And then finally, he develops the basis for spiritual power consisting in concentration due to the investigation and determined striving.
So, again, it's investigation.
Now, this investigation is to do in terms of Vipassana is to do, of course, with the three characteristics of existence.
You know, the cause of suffering, impermanence and not self.
But in ordinary daily life, it's always to keep that sort of sense of investigation, of curiosity, of reflection, right?
Of reflection as to what we're doing, why we're doing.
And of course, you can take that into any work that you're doing.
So now these four qualities, the zeal, the energy, the giving of your heart mind to what you're doing, the giving of your heart to what you're doing,
and this reflection, this constant reflection on what you're doing and investigation of what you're doing.
These four qualities are what lead you to success.
So these are not only for spiritual success in terms of liberation, but also for ordinary daily achievements.
So that's worth contemplating, no?
Absolutely.
And then we have the, so that's the sport of them.
So we've already got to 12, 37.
The next are the five faculties.
So these are the spiritual faculties, but again, they relate to our daily life, develops the faculty of faith, confidence.
Here, Bikubo is translated as faith, which has that double sort of meaning of belief, you know.
Best to think of it as a sort of real confidence.
And the confidence grows the more you practice, of course.
And in ordinary daily life, the more you bring mindfulness to bear, the more you affectionate mindfulness to bear, the more you see how it produces results for us.
And then there's, again, the faculty of energy.
There's always this putting energy into what we're doing.
faculty of mindfulness of course the faculty of concentration which remember is much more to do with a steadiness of attention you know being able to keep your attention on what you're doing and then finally the faculty of wisdom which here has two two meanings it has both the the wisdom that we have as from which we are working and it also has the meaning of insights
which is seeing things as they really are as we go from moment to moment.
So those are your five spiritual faculties.
Now, when somebody achieves first path and fruit and becomes a dream entrant, these are then known as powers.
So up until we are stream entrants, that sense of confidence is never absolutely completely established.
But when a person enters into the stream, has a deep enough insight into the way things are, of course, in a sense, that confidence now is based on personal direct experience and cannot be shaken, right?
even though under torture you might say that you didn't experience it.
That's of course a bit extreme.
So now we've had another 10, so I do believe that brings us up to 22.
Then there are the seven factors of enlightenment, the seven factors of awakening, which again have...
We mustn't see them only in terms of the actual vipassana practice, but in ordinary daily life.
So there's that awareness, mindfulness, you know, being our doing, being our doing.
And it always starts off with supported by seclusion, dispassion, cessation and the results of relinquishment.
So in ordinary daily life, really that's just constantly being aware of being taken over by things that we are attached to, things that we become dependent on to create this mental state of happiness and to slowly begin to let go of those things.
So the first one is the awareness.
Actually, on this on this list, it comes last, isn't it?
Not sure.
Just a minute.
So here it develops the mindfulness enlightenment factor.
OK, then the investigation of states, which is the.
curiosity and then the energy of course and then and now he's got a rapture but this really is the joy is the joy that we get from investigating something it's interest a sense of wonder as well a sense of wonder and the interest and the desire to investigate and then there's the tranquility just the general background
something and then there's the concentration of course which i've always thought the phrase steadiness of attention is closer to what we want since the word concentration of it has that feeling of tension about it or at least does for me and finally this equanimity which is that balanced heart mind
you know, positions of fear and aversion and prejudice and preference.
And also to have a certain, to come from a place where you're not holding on to a view in the sense of I'm right and everybody else is wrong.
This is the only way you can look at things.
To be much more open to the idea that all the views we have are a certain perspective
and that other people will have similar but slightly different perspectives so it's being open really open-minded open-hearted and that's the equanimity so those are your seven seven factors of enlightenment um so that's your uh your awareness i mean the way i do it is is the way that they match each other or balance each other so there's the awareness of course which keeps everything in balance
And then there's the concentration and the effort needed to maintain that.
There's the calmness that goes with the interest, or else you try to get overexcited or whatever.
And then there's this investigation, which is matched with this open heart mind.
Okay.
And of course, he says, then many disciples of mine abide this way, having reached the consummation and perfection of direct knowledge, direct experience.
So that's that brings us up to twenty nine.
OK, so we're getting getting there.
The next one is the Eightfold Path.
I have proclaimed to my disciples the way to develop.
the Noble Eightfold Path.
Here a disciple develops right view, right intention, right speech, right action, right livelihood, right effort, right mindfulness and right concentration.
So often this is taught as Sila Samadhi Panna.
So Sila is your morality, your ethics, right speech, right action, right livelihood, Sila Samadhi.
Samadhi refers to your meditation, which is, of course, right concentration and right awareness.
There's also usually right efforts put in there with that trilogy.
uh but of course right effort runs through everything yeah and so does the mindfulness it's all it's all mixed up together you know and uh and wisdom is of course the first two the the direct experience and how it begins to manifest in our intentions i prefer the word attitude so that's the noble a4 path that's a
We've now come to 37.
That's it.
Now, without any doubt, the Buddha did actually teach these qualities.
And basically, that's all we need to know.
In fact, we don't even need to know all this amount.
But those are 37 facts that lead to liberation.
Now, then Bhikkhu Thanissaro, whose writings and talks, I'm sure some of you know, has said that at that time, there were 37 different chords.
It was very difficult to tune
the strings of the of the wiener the wiener was like a guitar um loot and uh he's he's matched these 37 with the 37 uh different uh scales or modes or whatever but i i don't know where he gets that from but it's a lovely idea it's a lovely idea that uh
the Buddha was trying to connect his teachings with music, with what is beautiful, with melody.
And in a sense, he does that by doubling up on the faculties.
So if you remember, the five faculties were the confidence, the energy, the mindfulness, the concentration and the wisdom.
And they were bumped up to powers
when somebody entered the path and fruit, the first path and fruit.
And in that way, he was able to get his 37.
I don't know whether he did that consciously or whether it just happened.
It's just a little side note that we can keep in mind.
So these things are, again, for our contemplation.
But when it comes down to it, you know, keep it simple, make it simple.
That's Ajahn Tate's lovely quote.
I love to quote that.
Keep it simple.
Just, you know, affectionate awareness.
Be mindful of what we're doing.
Whenever we see something unwholesome arise, to try and be on it from the beginning and just let it go, let it pass.
Allow the energy to dissipate and then to reestablish the right attitude, the right intention in our minds.
So I hope I have now undermined any doubts that you might have had after our meeting with Upali and a little bit of fake news.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance and that they have undermined all doubt and that with your continued practice, you will become fully liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.
So we can begin our practice.